i do not have any ac units unfortunately
i sold out of those within the first two
days i brought them in this week
i didn't think it would be this hot i
mean i come here all the time but
today is just like really the surface of
the ground is super hot
we just have the air ceiling the the
fans yeah the fans we have fans and
that's all we just keep the
the windows open and we try to have that
a cross air you know like
makes it cool everything yeah yeah that
works really well and it saves a lot of
energy
yeah i think that we all should be doing
our part to save
as much energy conserve as much as we
can
yeah it may be the first day of summer
in the northern hemisphere but for some
50 million people in the u.s
summer has arrived early and hotter than
ever before in just the last week
high temperature records have been
shattered all across the western half
of the united states let's pull in the
map to show you what we're talking about
salt lake city in utah just saw its
hottest day
since record keeping began back in 1870
107 degrees fahrenheit that's 42 degrees
celsius you see it right there wyoming
also saw
new records in nevada las vegas
continues to flirt with its all-time
high
of 47 degrees celsius you see right
right there but the u.s city melting the
most
phoenix arizona which just set an
all-time record of five consecutive days
of 115 degrees fahrenheit you see it
right there that's
46 degrees celsius now the heat
is making severe droughts across the
western u.s go from bad to worse the
federal government is already planning
to declare
an official water shortage at lake mead
in august
lake mead's waters power hoover dam now
this picture
it tells the story doesn't it as of last
week lake mead's water level is at a
record low and there is no relief in
sight
the western u.s is in what scientists
are describing now as a climate
change-induced
mega-drought some even say that this
summer could be the hottest and the
driest in the millennium
and less water means more fire
2020 saw a record number of wildfires in
california oregon
and in washington state 2021 is expected
to be
worse stephen pine is a leading
environmental scientist who has written
extensively on fire and climate change i
want you to take a listen
to how he describes what is happening
i think what we're seeing with climate
change is that it is
acting on and exaggerating all kinds of
climatic
conditions and so it is making things
worse we're seeing
more frequent fires more severe fires
uh we're seeing them at a scale not just
in terms of area largeness but intensity
plus area combining i've got children
i've got grandchildren
what kind of world are they going to
inhabit it's going to be a very
different one
if the climate change trajectory isn't
flattened
then all those will be overridden i mean
all those
temporizing things all those small scale
things we do
will simply be overwhelmed my next guest
has also been sounding the alarm on the
increasing number of weather
catastrophes compounded by
climate change rachel cletus is with the
union of concerned scientists she joins
me tonight
from arlington massachusetts rachel it's
good to have you on
the program last year you testified
before a u.s
house committee and you warned of heat
waves droughts
and wildfires becoming more extreme and
more common
and that is exactly what is happening
now before our very eyes isn't it
yes absolutely it's very very sobering
to see
climate changes here and now this is not
about some distant future
we're seeing this terrible heat wave
that you just described on your program
unfolding around the western u.s right
now
we're seeing conditions of extreme
drought
setting up for a terrible wildfire
season that's already begun
it's already underway in the western u.s
and
we're just now in june so this is just
the front end of summer
very sobering rachel can you point to
any real
action or tangible measures of the u.s
government since you testified
last year before that committee
yeah so just to unpack it a little uh we
are here in this moment this terrible
drought and wildfire season
not because of any individual year this
is a multi-year trend that has been set
up
climate change is driving these very
extreme
high temperatures we're seeing earlier
snowpack melt
we're seeing the ground very very dry
in a multi-year fashion and that's
setting up a wildfire season of the kind
we're describing
we have a lot of catch-up to do and
that's just the bottom line so this
uh administration the new administration
that's come in this year
as well as congress really has a lot of
ground to make up
we have to be both investing in making
sure that our forests are healthy for us
ecosystems are healthy
that we're investing of course in the
emergency fire fighting and the relief
measures that communities need
but we have to be thinking about the
long-term trend here
we're not going to be able to avoid all
of these conditions
uh the fact is our current and past heat
trapping emissions
have already created really dangerous
conditions
so now the question is how can we try to
minimize the risk
i know as someone who studies the
climate you described
the election of president biden in
november like
waking up from a nightmare he
immediately rejoined the paris climate
agreement that is true but other than
that the world has been focused on his
infrastructure bill racial equity and
just recently on the transatlantic
alliances and
u.s russia relations have we overlooked
important climate change measures
look climate is connected to everything
it's connected to our economic
well-being it's connected to our future
prosperity
it's connected to our infrastructure
decisions because what we're finding is
when we fail to take climate risks into
account
our infrastructure is starting to fail
more and more
we're talking about wildfires for
example and last year we saw the power
grid in california failed repeatedly
in the face of these wildfire risks we
were seeing
utility companies take proactive
measures to shut down
power during high wildfire risk moments
and that left a lot of people these
rolling blackouts that have other
cascading impacts
or we saw the power grid itself trip
uh wildfires so we have to
any infrastructure we're investing in
right now as part of this american jobs
plan that president biden has outlined
needs to be both low carbon and climate
resilient to prepare for the future
that's really coming our way right now
you talked for example about the power
grid
and the connections with the low
water supply and we're seeing these
we're seeing hydropower being
reduced the access to hydropower because
of the low water levels in these
reservoirs
all of these conditions are impacting
our infrastructure and therefore we need
to be taking proactive measures to make
them more climate resilient going
forward
and rachel let me ask you how do you
grade the way
we the media are reporting on
whether extremes and climate change
well i think more and more we're seeing
reporting that's connecting the dots
between climate change and these
extreme disasters but probably not
enough and people are still looking at
them as one-off disasters instead of the
terrible trend that we've set up we have
a wildfire season right now that's
getting underway but we also here in the
united states have an above average
hurricane season that's forecasted
we're going to see these kinds of risks
collide and government agencies like in
the us the federal emergency management
agency are going to be tasked with
dealing
with multiple disasters at the same time
we're also seeing communities being hit
hard repeatedly
communities that were hit by wildfires
last year are still
struggling to get back on their feet
similarly with hurricane affected
communities in the gulf south and
the coastal u.s so this is where
we have a situation where dealing with
these as one-off disasters while they're
in the headlines is just not enough
we have to take proactive resilience
measures
you know we throw around these record
high temperatures all the time and we
assume they mean something to our
viewers
scientists in australia they're before
referring more and more instead
to what is known as the excess heat
factor which
factors in how much impact and stress a
heat wave has on people for example
in your opinion is that a better gauge
to use to communicate what climate
change is doing to our weather
and doing to us
yes we need some way to convey the truly
exceptional conditions that we have when
we have these
multi-day events of extreme heat because
you don't get that cooling effect at
night times
uh you get the human body being really
stressed especially people who are
working outdoors
like right now workers are working in
the fields
in the western us construction workers
even children who are doing sports
outdoors when you have these multi-day
heat events
there is no break and it is truly
catastrophic for the public health
for homeless for the incarcerated
population
and that's why we need a way of
conveying to the public the true risks
that they face to be really careful of
course to stay indoors and stay cool as
far as possible
but also some of these places are going
to get really unhealthy for people to
live in when we
look out into the future and that is
uh when we recognize that we have to
curtail the emissions that are fueling
climate change
there's a limit to what we can adapt to
do you still believe rachel that we can
save
the world in the climate as we know it
if we cut carbon emissions to zero no
later
than by 2050 is it still possible
look even at one degree celsius global
average temperature increase which we're
at right now a little over that we're
seeing some really profound effects
but yes we do still have a very
consequential
choice in terms of limiting how far and
how bad these impacts get we have to do
everything in our power to limit those
emissions
otherwise we will get really
catastrophic conditions
so we can't avoid all the harms but we
can limit some of the worst harms and we
should
and i have to ask you about we've still
got you here a carbon tax
on everything that that we buy services
everything that creates co2 emissions
would that be the most equitable way
to get rid of co2 emissions and to make
sure that we're all invested in that
a carbon tax is not a silver bullet
solution it can definitely be an
important powerful
tool but when we're thinking about
equity and justice we really have to be
thinking about
who's being hurt hardest and at the
foremost from these impacts and making
sure that they're protected that they
have the investments
in their communities right rachel cletus
with the union of concerned scientists
rachel it's good having you on the
program we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight please come back and
talk with us again thank you
thank you very much for having me